hey I'm Dave Rubin and this is the Rubin
report we're live on the YouTube today
and before I introduce my guest just a
quick reminder that you guys should
click Subscribe and make sure you turn
on notifications with that little bell
there otherwise you most likely won't
see our videos and we prefer if you see
the videos as long as we're doing them
ok then joining me today is an author
and Democratic presidential candidate
Marianne Williamson welcome to the Rubin
report thank you thank you so much for
having me
I'm thrilled to have you here I sense
it's gonna be a bit of a love fest cuz
that that seems to be your thing but you
already made my day because right before
we started you turn to my guys and you
said it might as pretty as Dave and I
feel like I've got all the quote that I
need out of you going forward okay so
let's just dive right in so truth be
told I did not know a tremendous amount
about you before the debate of a couple
weeks ago so let's just do a couple
minutes on who you are and what got you
to that stage and then we're gonna dive
into all the issues to talk about love
and healing crystals and everything else
oh so take it away well just tell me a
little bit about yourself what sort of
what got you to be the person that is
now standing on stage with that other
crew I understand I was born and raised
in Houston Texas and in 1983 I began
lecturing here in Los Angeles at a place
called the philosophical Research
Society on a set of books called a
Course in Miracles
the Course in Miracles is not a religion
there's no dogma there's no doctrine it
has been described by some people as a
self-study program of spiritual
psychotherapy it's a book about
forgiveness and love and it's based on
universal spiritual themes of all the
great religious teachings of the world
how to be more loving how to be more
forgiving mercy compassion showing up in
the world as a more loving person and
how that heals everything right after I
began lecturing over there the AIDS
crisis emerged full-blown and Los
Angeles was particularly hard-hit so it
took a while for Western medicine to
have
talk to offer not that they weren't
trying but this was a terrible deadly
disease that had they kept playing cards
and playing cards it took a while and
also the institutionalized religious
identities also working through whatever
they were having to work through I don't
know well quite silent for a long time
so here was this woman been a young
woman at that time over in Los Feliz
talking about a God who loves you no
matter what and the miracles that happen
would love his presence so gay men in
Los Angeles in a very real way gave me
my career because it became a thing with
the AIDS crisis that this this this one
Center now Louise Hay was also this was
the time when Louise Hay was doing her
thing called the hey ride so there was a
lot of showing up for emotional
psychological and spiritual support to
sufferers within the AIDS community at
that time I wrote my first book also we
started an organization here in Los
Angeles we start an organization to give
non non medical support services both
here and in New York called the Centers
for living and then one of the programs
of the the Los Angeles Center for living
was and still is project angel food
which delivered nonprofit which
delivered free home meals to homebound
people with AIDS when today that
organization still exists anita served
over 11 million meals and i say that to
point out that my work as someone
talking and writing about spiritual
topics has never been separated from
showing up in very real practical ways
as a nonprofit activist etc whether it
has to do with people with life
challenging illnesses or people living
in poverty or people
racial healing reconciliation I've
always been very dirt under my
fingernails with my spiritual work
because to me there is no religious or
spiritual practice that gives any of us
a pass on addressing the suffering of
other sentient beings so if I had a time
machine and I could go back to that
woman in the in the midst of this and I
see you're probably talking about what
from mid-80s 83 started and then the and
all of that started
mid 80s late eighties so if I was
talking to that version of yourself and
was to say you know in about thirty five
some odd years you're gonna be on stage
running for president of the United
States and at the first debate you're
kinda gonna be the one that most people
are talking about what would you have
said hmm all right all right so let's
let's dive into a couple things here as
of this morning I saw an article that
you are now polling ahead of Beto of
Kristen Jill and brand and Cory Booker
in New Hampshire not bad
what do you make of what's going on here
do you think this is all because of the
first debate debate performance level
I'm having a conversation that other
candidates are not having now first of
all let me say all the candidates are
really lovely people and I don't feel
I'm running against anyone I'm running
with a lot of really good people but I
am having a conversation that is
different than those whose careers have
been entrenched in the political
establishment for decades because I'm
not prosecuting a case against Donald
Trump but I am prosecuting a case
against the system that produced him and
I challenge the idea that only those
people whose careers have been interest
in the system that drove us into this
ditch are the only people qualified to
lead us out of this ditch you know
slavery didn't end because the political
establishment woke up one day and said
let's end slavery the abolitionist
movement actually began with the early
of intellicus and the early Quakers the
people stepped in and that's what began
the path to abolition same with giving
women the right to vote the political
establishment didn't wake up one day and
say let's give women the right to vote
with the women's suffrage movement it
was an example of the people stepping in
which then led the political
establishment to make changes so in a
weird way does it seem like we're sort
of absurdly focused on politics all the
time instead of actually what you're
talking about which is more of a
movement of the people that isn't it's
not a very political per se well I think
that's sort of the point abolition was a
moral stance women's suffrage was a
moral stance and the same with civil
rights it wasn't the political
establishment that caused it
it was the moral stance articulated by
Martin Luther King in the civil rights
movement and that is my point regarding
what is needed today
it was the people stepping in with what
Martin Luther King called a coalition of
conscience that then caused a change so
when you ask me what do I make of my
polling higher than certain really cool
people
lovely people who are entrenched within
the political establishment my point is
that the change that is emerging from
the bottom of things
today it the the deepest change the
deepest yearning that is welling up
within people it's not necessarily
coming from the same status quo that
created the problem it's coming from
within people who want to see an
interruption in the political status quo
so when you ask me what I make of this
it's what's happening it's what needs to
happen the people need to step in we
have been living for the last 40 years
under what did I believe an illusion
that I trickle-down economics where all
that a corporation has to do is is is is
exercised fiduciary responsibility
toward its towards its stockholders even
if that's at the expense of other
stakeholders like workers or the
community or the environment without any
sense of moral or ethical responsibility
to anything beyond that fiduciary
responsibility we were sold on that on
the assumption that all this money would
trickle down from the stockholder class
it would lift all boats
well after 40 years I think it's it's
fair to say the jury is in and not only
has this this economic theory that has
so corrupted our government and hijacked
our moral system it has not lifted all
boats I just left millions of people
without even a life vest it has led to
the largest wealth inequality since 1929
it has led us to the point where 1% of
Americans own more wealth than the
bottom 90% and 40% of Americans in the
richest country in the world live with
chronic economic anxiety millions and
millions of Americans for whom there is
daily tension and anxiety what will
happen if I get sick what will happen if
one of my children get sick how will I
send my kids to college how will I pay
off these college loans and Dave no one
can know
can soar living with that kind of
tension it's debilitating its
emotionally and psychologically
debilitating when we are in that place
we can't create we can't produce could
you be doing this this that is your
life's work which is obviously
successful which is obviously a conduit
for the expression of your creativity
and your enthusiasm could you be doing
this if you were crippled by constant
worry of that oh you're gonna just make
it 40 percent of all Americans who I
believe have just as much talent as you
and me Dave just as much who are who are
shackled in ways that you're not
supposed to be shackled by material
conditions in the richest country in the
world rather that situation that I'm
describing is the result of specific
political policies which over the last
40 years have represented a pattern by
which major resources of this government
had been placed in the hands of the very
few at the expense of the many now you
and I both know if you make it into the
club in America no place better than
this but what's happened in America is
that not enough people can make it into
the club and that bodes ill for all of
us because the American the whole
concept of American democracy is that
this should be a space of possibility
where anybody if they work hard enough
gonna have a chance okay so you gave me
a lot there and I want to dive into some
of the economic parts of that and in a
little bit but you said something there
when I knew I wanted to have you on the
show was during the debate you said
something that I thought this is
actually completely unheard of for a
Democrat at least in 2019 to say you
said I do not believe that the average
American is racist and yet it seems if
you watch mainstream media we are just
caught in you're racist you're racist
you're a bigot you're a fascist you're a
homophobia or transphobia scam and
unfortunately and I say this as someone
that was you know that I still consider
myself liberal but I'm I'm a lifetime
Democrat really at least until the last
two or so years a lot of that's coming
out of the left and from the Democrats
this labeling of a everyone as racist
well I hear you and you're leaving out a
very
factor which is that the president at
least based on his tweets and his
comments yes so I agree with you that a
smug self-righteous intolerant
left-winger is no less dangerous of
emotional fabric of our country then a
smug self-righteous intolerant right
winger and some of the shut down you
shut up you didn't say the right thing
comes from the left as much as the right
these days I will give you that and it's
dangerous and it's wrong however this
president says things and is involved in
it right now which by any by any measure
are racist comments and then where else
were you going with that well what do
you find it sort of almost impossible to
have any kind of political conversation
it doesn't get whittled down to this
because that sort of seems like where
we're at I don't even really know who's
talking about policy anymore or or
really what I would rather talk about
all day long which is how much
government is needed to do anything
which i think would be a rich place to
have a discussion complicated than that
I think we need to walk and chew gum at
the same time on one hand I certainly
understand what you mean about how the
public square is a place where it's
almost impossible to have a conversation
these days although you just need to not
be on Twitter too much there are places
that just make that worse that's not the
place for intelligent political
conversation yeah however I'm a Jew and
I remember the first time I went to your
sham if you ever ever in Jerusalem I
mean you know having been there
Hitler was saying things for years he
was saying what he believed and he was
and he said what he was gonna do the
world didn't take him seriously and so
much and books have been written so many
books have been written in years of
analysis why didn't people leave why
didn't take it seriously and the answer
was clearly cuz nobody everybody thought
it was a crazy guy nobody took it
seriously nobody thought it could
actually lead anywhere but then once he
started actually doing what he did and
you looked back and you know you should
you see this those films at Yad Vashem
he was saying it and I'm sorry we are
naive to underestimate the danger of
that kind of hate speech when it is
coming from the highest purchase of
government
so do you fundamentally believe that
Trump has that in him that I'm not here
to sign I don't need to psychoanalyze
the president what about like what I'm
speaking to is the effect on government
and the country the words of the
President and the words of the president
are very serious and the words of the
president affect not only people in this
country but they affect other countries
too everybody's listening to the to the
words of the of the American president
and yes I think it's time for Americans
to awaken to the lessons of history yes
I do this is very very serious
now when you said what we also need to
be thinking about I do too
including the fact that you know now
we're going through this business well
the president said this about these
Congress women and now these Congress
women and what is the Democratic Party
going to say about this congresswoman
where I do think this is enough is
enough has to do with the fact that the
deeper levels of systemic racism and
there is systemic racism in this country
ways in which social policy economic
policy criminal policy is tinged by
obvious racial prejudice there is no
doubt so can you give me an example of
that yes you could take white people and
black people use drugs at the same rate
but a black person is liable to get a
far harsher sentence for the same drug
offense so there is racial disparity
throughout our criminal sentencing
another example is there are millions of
American children who go to school every
day in schools that don't even have the
adequate school supplies with which to
teach a child to read and if a child
cannot learn to read by the age of eight
then the chances of high school
graduation are drastically diminished
and the chances of incarceration are
drastically increased these children
live many of them in what's called
America's domestic war zones where
psychologists say the PTSD of a
returning veteran from Afghanistan or
Iraq is no more severe than the than the
PTSD of these children now these
children this is how it works in America
we primarily base our educational
funding on proper
taxes and since there's higher poverty
among black children that means that if
you were a child growing up in a nice
neighborhood in America you have a very
good chance of a high quality public
school education but public school
education should not be better for the
rich than for the poor so because most
of these poverty ridden neighborhoods
are neighbourhoods inhabited by people
of color not that poverty is only people
of color even though among people of
color you have a higher rate of poverty
poverty itself is a huge and almost
ubiquitous reality in America among
white people too so when you see things
like this for instance as president I
wish to see this change I wish to see
every school in America a palace of
learning culture and the arts there has
been described there was a term that was
first coined by marian wright edelman
cradle to Prison Pipeline and when you
look at the sentencing of black people
and people of color in our prison system
absolutely to deny that there was not a
terrible racial injustice going on
underneath there is just to willfully
deny the facts so there's this video of
going around today although I think it's
from January where you were giving a
speech and you had the white people in
the audience basically go up to the
black people in the crowd and they kind
of put their hand on them and then you
read a we almost was like a sermon
really what it was just it was your
speech and you talked about white
supremacy and you talked about
reparations and all of these things so
for me watching it as someone that I
despised identity politics I think it is
what has it's it's the root of almost
everything that is wrong right now which
is why I'm struggling so much with what
I would say is my former team let's say
there was a certain collective guilt to
what you were saying that that was
really troubling to me I was really
struggling when I was watching it not
that your intentions were not good you
know what I mean but that the idea of
these sort of guilt ridden white people
many of whom probably well certainly
none of them one in that room owned
slaves and probably many of them never
came
from descendants of slaves nor would I
think that you're guilty for your
father's sins much less your
great-great-great grandfather sins etc
there was a certain collective guilt to
it that that struck me is as scary does
that ring with you no not at all but
I'll tell you why where's a difference
between taking blame and taking
responsibility the Germans German nation
has paid 89 billion dollars to Jewish
organizations since World War two and by
the time they started paying those
reparations it was the generation after
the generation after the war many of the
people started paying those reparations
with children during that war nobody was
saying but it was to the people who
survived not two not two generations
absolutely - no it's the Jewish
organizations absolutely a friend
absolutely wasn't just to the people who
survived and let's talk about how few
survived okay yeah so no it was not it
was to future generations this is the
issue it is a spiritual concept in
Catholics Catholics go to confession and
in Judaism there is the concept of Yom
Kippur which is the day of atonement and
in alcoholics Anonymous you have to take
a fearless moral inventory and admit the
exact nature of your character defects
whether it's an individual or a nation
you can't have the future you want
unless you're willing to clean up the
past now nobody is saying I mean my
grandparents came from Russia my in two
generation to go nobody's I don't
believe that you know I personally I
didn't own slaves that's not what we're
talking about when you talk about
national atonement and national amends
for instance I want to tell you
something else that I think a lot of
Americans don't realize in 1988 Ronald
Reagan signed the American Civil
Liberties act and everybody who had been
a prisoner a surviving prisoner of the
Japanese internment camps in World War
two were given between twenty and twenty
two thousand dollars now this is the
deal a lot of them but that that was the
direct people that was yeah well let's
let's talk about this the first slaves
were brought over from Africa enslaved
people 1619 a slavery was not abolished
until 1865 so that's 250 years that was
followed by another hundred years of
institutionalized violence against black
people in America lynchings
segregation Ku Klux Klan this is
domestic terror black code laws which
ensured subpar economic and social and
political opportunities when slavery was
abolished in this country the US
government promised because there were
four to five million slaves at that time
the the US government promised that
every former enslaved person family of
four would receive between a forty acres
and a mule that would have given people
who didn't have where were their to go
like Martin Luther King said they were
free but where would them what were
there for you to write I most never got
it most never got it so there was an
economic gap there that was simply never
closed a hundred years later the civil
rights movement the civil rights act
ended dismantled segregation then the
next year the Voting Rights Act gave
equal access to the polls so I'm not
minimizing the things that have been
done that have corrected the struggles
the sacrifices of any of our ancestors
black or white I'm not saying we haven't
done anything
the issue is however that point of
economic restitution has never been made
and the legacies of that economic
injustice have continued even to the
point where now we're sliding backwards
mass incarceration means we're sliding
backwards racial disparity and criminal
sentencing means sliding backwards all
these voter suppression acts because the
Voting Act
Road and Rights Act was chipped away at
we're sliding backwards so for me the
issue of reparation so first of all this
issue of atonement I have a faith leader
this is what I've done for 35 years so
when I was doing ritualized apologies
from white people to black there is
turbulence there's turbulence under the
under the under the waterline you know
if you go to Germany have you ever been
to Germany if you went to Germany 30
years ago you really felt all the
Holocaust guilt and it's amazing how
much has been flushed out now because
the generations did the right thing and
that war was over in 1945 civil war was
over in 1865 and we are still at the
effect of this underlying stuff that we
we move on from one June of
to another but something dies yeah well
well do you think there's a little bit
of a risk in sort of yeah I mean a
couple of times you're referencing the
genocide of the Jews to slavery seems
like a little bit of a slippery slope
there now I don't even know how we can
say that actually and I say that as a
Jew if you read up much on slavery yeah
we're talking object slavery day I mean
nobody's in a contest nobody has a
monopoly on human suffering
this was object slavery million and also
if you started slavery in 1619 and you
had two and a half years two and a half
centuries and then at the end for there
were four to five million enslaved
people do you realize generation have to
generation how many millions of people
we're talking about right well I'm not
diminishing that but you can also talk
about the extermination of 6 million
people in the amount of people that
never lived because of that that would
be alive or your ancestors from well any
from Russia who had never given anything
and came here whoa wait a minute wait a
minute
but the Germans have pay reparations
that's kind of my point the fact that
Germany paid reparation Germany has done
full-on Maricopa Germany has known
full-on Maricopa nothing short of full
on Maricopa plus reparations plus a
guarantee that every generation there to
form would receive full Holocaust
education that's kind of my point they
cleaned it up and the fact that it
doesn't mean that they can make the
Holocaust not have happened but it has
had a tremendous moral psychological and
emotional affect reconciling Germany
with the Jews of Germany and the rest of
Europe it that's what reparations do it
is just like in a personal relationship
all that a nation is is a group of
people so the same psychological and
emotional and spiritual principles that
that prevail within the journey of an
individual prevail within the journey of
a nation if you are i wronged each other
somebody was gonna need to apologize in
order for us to clean it up and not only
that well but if you were i but that's
different than the collective me but
it's not that's my point
now if you
different than the collective than your
right but if you don't believe it's
different than the collector okay so
that just might be a fundamental
difference and that's fine I mean I
don't think I'm guilty of anyone else
this is not about guilt it's a
difference between take and guilt and
responsibility there's difference if you
if you have a a company that takes over
another company you inherit their assets
and you inherit their debts and so
America inherited the debts of the of
the south and also there was a lot of
listen systemic racism that wasn't just
in the south either you know after World
War two the German Chancellor's and
Prime Minister's there was a lot of
apologizing that went on in my book
Illuminata I talked about this and you
know something else
there was a pope around three popes ago
I think his name was John Paul I get
some of the John's and the Paul's mixed
up but that the it was John Paul and in
the last few years before he died he he
uttered these really amazing encyclicals
and he went around apologizing and he
apologized on behalf of the Catholic
Church for the Inquisition and he
apologized on behalf of the Catholic
Church for all kinds of amazing things I
remember what's he handing out cash to
pardon was he handing out cash no I
don't know he was just no he was not
passing out cash right but these are
separate things though a human and a
man's are two separate things and what
you were talking about seeing online was
atonement so if I may there what he said
no he coined a phrase which I thought
was so brilliant purification of memory
and he said if you do not apologize for
a what he called a sin in your past the
new remains sub remain unconscious of
the ways you repeated in the future I
thought that was incredible so he was
speaking there about institutions
apologizing now in terms of cash versus
not mirrors atonement and there is
immense if you look at something like
the principles of Alcoholics Anonymous
you were tone but you make amends where
possible if you stole a thousand dollars
from me and then you came up to me and
said I'm Mary Ann I am so sorry that I
stole that thousand dollars from you I
would feel I really appreciate your
apology and I
also like my cash back so the idea of
making an amends in addition to
atonement is the way you truly close the
circle of Records right so I think our
disconnect here is just individual
versus collective because I hear you I
stole a thousand dollars from you right
but but not only did I not own slaves
but nobody and my family did nobody
nobody in your family did but so how
much would be the right amount well then
I mean how much are we gonna have people
okay first of all I hand people I don't
think we're handing people but I hear
what you're saying yeah so so let's talk
about this because I've been in this
conversation long enough to know no
matter what number I utter some are
gonna say it's too much some are gonna
say it's too little okay so there's no
magic number let's just first of all say
four or five million slaves or enslaved
people because people are very sensitive
about the terminology today at the end
of the Civil War if every enslaved
family of four for millions laid family
for was given 40 acres and a mule and
you looked at that 40 acres in terms of
today's acreage in today's math it would
be trillions of dollars okay what I am
proposing is between 200 to 500 billion
to be dispersed over a period of 20
years now let's look at this in
perspective we spend 750 billion in one
year on our military expenditures so I'm
saying 200 to 500 disbursed over 20
years and what I'm proposing is a is a
council of black leaders a reparations
council is it worth there are people
professor sandy daredi at Duke
University Tana has he coats there are
many people who have done scholarly work
on this subject for a very long time
what I'm proposing is that the
stipulation of the US government would
be that the money be spent on projects
of economic and educational renewal now
within that stipulation the the US
government be turning over a lot of
money yeah we certainly have a right to
have some like what is for but within
that stipulation of projects of economic
and educational renewal it would be up
to this
reparations counsel which obviously
needs to be very carefully chosen to
decide how during that 20 year period
the money is to be dispersed so I guess
so there's a couple things there so one
I think we also have a certain
disconnect on and which is fine
completely on just sort of what
government is actually able to do or can
do I just don't think government can
sort of do these these types of things
like it's not I don't I just don't think
it's the purpose of government I mean
would we be so is the answer that we'd
be taxing a first generation Latino
immigrant who just moved here who's
struggling to make ends meet we're gonna
tax him and take somewhere well take
some of his we're gonna have to tax
people to pay for this right well I
wouldn't be the money has to come from
somewhere right so yeah so the guy who
just moved here the issue is we don't
have to tax new people we need to stop
cutting the taxes of the very richest
among us we need to repeal that 2017 tax
cut there was a two trillion dollar tax
cut they gave eighty three cents of
every dollar to the very richest earners
and corporations under this this
illusion this this con our and about
particular on economics even though
there's no basis anywhere this is
actually going to stimulate the economy
I would put back in the middle-class tax
cuts
then you stop these incredible and
immoral corporate subsidies why did we
give twenty six billion dollars twenty
six billion alone to the fossil fuel
companies last year then you say the
United States government will no longer
not be able to negotiate with big
pharmaceutical companies for drug prices
so you stop that and then you say to the
billionaires in this country three
percent we get three the government gets
three percent and you say to those who
have five hundred million and more two
percent makes sense you know I know
billionaires who say sounds right to me
I know a billionaire who said to me
living in this town who once said to me
my taxes are so low it's obscene and
what's is why why does he need the
government to do something with his
money I mean that that seems to be the
theme with these people they keep saying
oh we've got all this money they should
just take more of our money but you know
they do all the tricks not to pay out
more money and then they just do it to
sound
rich people aren't what I think not
every rich person is greedy not every
poor person is is it's pure and Noble I
agree with what you were saying before I
don't label people and then say because
of your socio-economic group or because
of your culture well I know who you are
I don't think we want to go there I
agree with you entirely let's not do
that so okay so let's let's say we did
this and I actually didn't want to get
totally caught up in the reparations
thing but we're here so let's say we do
this what actually causes then the shift
we're oK we've had this council of black
leaders we've figured out how we're
gonna pay for this thing we pay okay
people have this money what causes them
the healing for people to say okay we're
good to go now we can move forward in a
completely different way it's a very
important question and and and it's
exactly the kind of conversation we need
to be having if you just have for
instance what some people call
race-based policies this provides
economic restitution but it doesn't
address the underlying moral
psychological and emotional issues a
reparations carry an inherent Maricopa
they carry an inherent acknowledgment of
a wrong that has been done a debt that
is owed and a willingness to pay it it
has a psychological and emotional effect
if you know this as well as I do
everybody's watching this knows there's
all this underlying racial tension in
this country it's not spoken it's
resentment it's it's almost like now in
my lifetime I've certainly seen the ways
in which racial issues have gotten
better but at the same time you see how
certain things are unwinding almost
getting worse and so we need that really
feels right to you that feels like a
media makeup to me I don't think racism
that's why I was so thrilled when I
heard you make that statement I don't
think most Americans are racist most
America races but I don't that's not my
experience that's not my belief but what
is my belief is that the average
American is woefully under educated
about the history of race in the United
States and that's why I find and I find
it's in very white state I find it in
New Hampshire and Iowa with people
standing up applauding the idea why
because I go through the timeline two
and a half centuries of
slavery we talk of an abject slavery
here then another hundred years of
institutionalized violence what do you
call lynchings if not domestic terror
when you call Ku Klux Klan if not
domestic terror institutionalized white
supremacy and segregation this was
violence perpetrated against the people
350 years because it was a hundred years
after the Civil War before the Civil
Rights Act 350 years of
institutionalized violence against a
people that's longer than our country
has been in existence so the idea of a
of a of an economic restitution by the
middle of the twentieth century this was
considered just civilized behavior and
and that is what advanced countries do
do you worry that as someone that comes
from a sort of a spiritual healing side
of this that the collectivist portion on
this right we just sort of have an
impasse do you worry that that that sort
of collectivist guilt makes people feel
guilty about things that have nothing to
do with them and what what the damage
that that could do to people that have
literally nothing to do with it doesn't
have to talk about this within a slavery
context or a holocaust context but just
sort of collectivism as a general rule
that it makes people attach emotions to
themselves that have nothing to do with
them as an individual no I don't and
that's never been my experience I've
been doing this for many years people
are smart they people are smart there's
no guilt there I know I can't say I feel
guilty personally that's not what's
happening but I can see that my country
has this is a long and torturous
relationship between blacks and whites
in America it goes back to the very
beginning and relationship is a journey
between people and between peoples and
that journey of healing and journey of
reconciliation makes a difference
because Germany has done the right thing
you feel in a generation of young
Germans so much guilt flushed out
Holocaust guilt has been flushed out
that's what we're talking about we're
ending the guilt
we're talking about getting past this
torturous a phase that's lasted 400 psin
right but also in a weird way then they
opened up because they have this sort of
residual guilt still they opened up
their borders and let in a million and a
half people that then have
you know sort of cause all sorts of
other problems with integration and
financially you just made a connection
between those policies and leftover
guilt from the Holocaust I'm not I'm not
sure every German or every German
scholar a German politician would agree
with you about well I don't think
everyone would but I think many would
what there was a surge elegantly yeah
but how would you explain that so many
other countries over there did it as
well well that would be a whole other
conversation about your sort of how the
EU operates and so yeah yeah globalism
and a whole bunch of other things yeah
we have a history and now what's
happening at the border now this
president is trying very hard to change
this but we have a in all fairness to
trump like much of this was beginning to
change before we have a history of
assimilation immigrant assimilating in
this country that Europe doesn't have so
that's why we haven't had previous to
this era in our history are the kind of
problems that the Europeans have had but
I'm not I'm not minimizing that you have
an issue that there's an issue there but
I don't think we should complain it with
what's happening with that race in
America right okay so just to end this
portion so to get back to that question
of sort of okay so you figure out what
these payouts are or however you want to
word it how do we get to the end of it
how do you go for in 20 years you said
uh Panama
listen I'm presently well how do you get
over the the general idea of well that's
just not enough on my life still not
what I want it to be you you have to
have to have a big enough number that
you're not gonna have a bunch of young
people saying yeah well you didn't give
us enough I mean that's why it has to be
a big enough number right but you think
that number exists I mean I just think
that's against sort of the way okay
that's a known negotiation like any
other you know I've said to a professor
Derrida everyone talked about it okay
I'm president I called professor Garrity
we talked about who should come to Camp
David because we don't have a weekend
we're just gonna talk this thing through
and it's gonna be a contract negotiation
so for instance a couple of black
leaders have said to me well but I mean
you know what if we don't think that's
enough I said that's what a contract
negotiate is all about you might say
well that's not enough we're gonna wait
and
so then the assumption is well we get
more 10 years 15 years from now I don't
know or would you get less because so
many immigrants are coming over from
Ghana Nigeria in Kenya so but that a day
that's what a contract negotiation is no
president who has a plan it has you know
the president doesn't have a magic wand
which right now thank God yeah so I'm
not saying elect me and this is going to
happen I'm saying elect me and this is
the plan we're going to we're going to
really sit down and enter into
negotiations and see if this can happen
do you want to be President or do you
want to be sort of like a like that
there's almost be like a side thing next
to president sort of like where we're in
the you know in many other countries
there's a predator dn't and a prime
minister where they're sort of we have a
constitution I'm fine with the
Constitution I'm not suggesting we alter
the Constitution no no I mean that I
actually need that more spiritually
where a lot of the things are talking
about maybe I think we need to review
the role of the presidency franklin
roosevelt said that the primary
responsibility of the presidency is not
the administrative aspect he said the
administrative aspect is secondary and
the primary role of the presidency is
moral leadership it's only been recently
that we've seen the role of president as
so technocratic so administrative you
know you can have the best car mechanic
in the world the best car mechanic may
or may not know what road should you
drive to new to New Hampshire you know
we need to include within the notion of
the presidency vision and and an
imagination and the ability to harness
imagination and moral certitude you know
this idea you know experienced
politicians experienced politicians took
us into Iraq you know there was plenty
of experience there was no wisdom
there was no moral certitude and so yeah
absolutely I not only want to be
president I think I'm the one who would
beat Donald Trump because I believe that
for whatever reasons we want to talk
about that and I believe on the best
woman for the job let's talk a little
bit about just sort of the race in
general and just all the stuff that you
have to be involved in now okay so the
Spanish at the debates everybody
speaking in Spanish
it struck me as sort of the worst sort
of pandering my mouse and I tweeted that
first night I tweeted I need to learn
Spanish by 9:00 tomorrow night exploded
on the internet yeah I doubt I kind of
have a feeling that the men who did that
didn't end up real happy that they had
done this yeah but doesn't that strike
you as sort of that sort of identity
politics thing that I'm talking about
where you're just handing people this
nothing of course it that I'm not you
know I always say III talk about the
same thing whether I'm talking to rich
people poor people english-speaking
people spanish-speaking people gay
people straight people and Jewish people
Christian people Muslim people I'm
talking to the American and all of us
that's what matters now we need to have
an American conversation even when we
talk about reparations to me it's not a
black agenda it's an American agenda so
I agree with you that's that's kind of
silly and um hasn't hasn't really helped
ya was your mic cut there was that whole
thing where Andrea was saying this mic
was cut and then you there were a couple
times I've tried to get in there and I
and there was no sound at my mic that
absolutely happened yeah now they've
said they didn't cut anybody's mic but
that was my experience what's it like
just the general circus before the whole
thing first of all the other people were
running on lovely people that has been
um I've really been impacted by that
they're lovely people do you think they
were all kind of shocked by you there
was one picture that kind of went viral
where like everyone and I think when I
did my thing about love I saw Kirsten
Gillibrand look at gorilla hair like and
I you know there's been a lot of funny
memes about that and I think some of its
justified I was on the floor laughing
also I've never done this before
but I don't I don't regret the substance
of anything I said so really for other
people I think a lot of people who
laughed then also said yeah but when you
actually look at what she said well
that's why I wanted to have you here
because I know we have some sort of
fundamental differences on just sort of
what the role of government is like it's
just it's fairly obvious but you're
obviously
person and all of those things but I
thought when you said the thing about
love even though that in a weird way not
in your sense but in for the average
person that has nothing to do with
politics sort of right not through your
lens but for the average earth and is
nothing to do politics but I thought
well that makes more sense than anything
else that I heard up here today let me
ask you a question yeah looking at the
world today looking at the world since
9/11 particularly who can say hate has
nothing to do with politics well I don't
think well it's not that hate or love
have anything to do with politics but
I'm very serious yeah hatred gave birth
to terrorism hatred is behind Nazism
hatred Hey in other words when it comes
to the negative emotions nobody doubts
the part negative emotions play in in in
in creating and determining political
dynamics so does love what do you think
the civil rights movement was it was it
was a it was a spirit centered movement
of the heart so is the original
abolitionist movement this idea what
love you you told me that you don't have
children
yeah but you have people you love is
there anything in your life that would
motivate you more than your loving
someone and when somebody needs help
what do we do for them because you love
them people ask me what is the politics
of love it's not mysterious you see a
hungry child you feed them you see a a
child who's not educated you feed them
you see a sick person you help them you
see a poor person struggling
unnecessarily you help them and you see
a planet which is rife with potential
conflict you wage peace yeah you you you
you love your planet enough to no longer
recklessly degrade it and you love your
planet enough to repair it you love your
great grandchildren who will never even
meet enough to to pass public policy
that will not only serve you but will
serve other generations as well it's not
such a mysterious thing love you know
Martin Luther King said power without
love is reckless and abusive and love
without power is sentimental and anemic
I'm talking about a
powerful and intelligent and wise love
without which I think it's very
questionable whether or not we will even
survive the 21st century so do you think
it's possible that sort of the road to
hell is paved with good intentions here
because a lot of these things that
you're talking about so everything all
the examples you just gave I'm for those
things I give money to poor people and I
can and I volunteer and I can and things
that I do it's sort of the personal
level but that it seems like a lot of
the answers that are coming out from
everybody on the Democratic side right
now are just that the government should
do these things and I would me
personally would always be leery of the
government because the government is the
people that put people in slavery the
government is the thing that that
exterminated six million Jews etc etc so
my preference would always be that we're
always taking power away from the
government we're giving the government
less money so that it will spend less
and do less things so that we can do all
of those things in our personal lives
and I wish I heard more out of from the
Democrats about that sort of thing there
is a healthy skepticism that anyone
should feel any American should feel
left or right towards government
overreach and left this field just as
much you do it just tends to be in
different places okay I stay out of our
bedroom etc okay so healthy skepticism
about overreach by government but let's
not kid ourselves Dave the people we're
talking about government doing less
today aren't saying small government
they're saying let's just give the money
to corporate control so where's you're
saying you don't want overreach by
government I'm saying what it has turned
into in this country it's code less
listened to less overreach by government
has turned into huge overreach by
corporate forces so all the money that
you're saying well I don't want the
government to do that all that money
just been marched over to short-term
profit maximization for health insurance
companies and big pharmaceutical
companies and gun manufacturers and
chemical companies and fossil fuel
companies and defense contractors they
are overreach the overreach of this new
matrix of corporate overlords is to me
to be feared just as much as overreach
by government so you think that's the by
the way no amount you talked about how
you give no amount of private charity
and we always need private charity and
government can't do everything nor
should government do everything but no
amount
of private charity can can compensate
for a basic lack of social justice you
know you can give a million dollars and
it's also wonderful but basically
because of our tax structure billions
are going to the same situation that
makes it so difficult for that person so
that just dropping a million dollars
into a charity it helps but it doesn't
in any way change the fundamental
pattern of injustice what do you make of
the whole sort of game that you have to
play to be part of this now you need
some of those things to go viral you
sort of you said the love thing and you
didn't know what the reaction was gonna
be and all of that that has nothing to
do with whatever our differences might
be it's irrelevant it's like that has
nothing to do with the policy or the
ideas but just the game to keep your
your name out there make sure you get
enough people to give you enough money
so you can get to the next debate first
of all what you and I have talked about
here President Eisenhower said the
American mind at its best is both
liberal and conservative what you have
articulated are high-minded conservative
principles and I hope that you feel I've
articulated some high-minded liberal
principles begin and young between those
two is the American mind at its best
I had a carto layin here a couple weeks
ago he was maybe a version of that yeah
the the problem the enemy of America
today and it is an enemy an opponent of
our democratic institutions is not a
conservative mentality or liberal
mentality it's a corporatist mentality
where short-term short-term profits for
economics over overshadow everything
there that that's that's not a righteous
conversation but when you keep referring
today to our differences this is that's
healthy differences those would bethe
just called political debate in America
yeah that's what a free society is well
that's why we need more of that's
actually the answer for people to
actually see what you and I've done here
today oh you can have a healthy debate
and conversation Oh where's the liberal
principle where is a conservative
principle then and both are important
yeah yeah believe it or not I actually
consider myself a liberal I consider
myself an old-school JFK liberal it's
just the things have been flipped in
such a crazy way that I hear you like
the things that I'm laying out here it
sounds it sounds sort of I know and the
labels are all nonsensical now and
the help the labels themselves don't
help and the Constitution didn't mention
political parties and George Washington
warned us against them and that's part
of the labels and the filters as far as
the dog-and-pony show my experience
particularly as a candidate is that
there are two separate political
universes
when is the dog-and-pony show who's up
who's down what the polls say how much
money what the pundits say and then
there's the real deal particularly in
the early primary States Iowa New
Hampshire Nevada South Carolina where
people know how much power they have
Californians have that power now too
because of the early voting that starts
next February third but I don't think
right the California isn't really taken
and what that means yet right but when
you're actually talking to people who
know but the power doesn't lie in Steve
karnaki the power lies in what we vote
or what we talk us it's very profound
and I feel in the honor it's just an
honor to be part of it and it's deeply
meaningful and that's what politics
should be politics should be a deeply
meaningful conversation and a conduit
for the higher aspirations of the
American people the fact that it has
been turned into something other than
that is what you and I know need to
change yeah so you're worried that
everything has become too political
right I mean I talked about that oh I'm
worried about what politics has become
it's not that I'm worried that things
have become too political life is
political art all the political means is
our collective behavior and collective
behavior has consequences just like
individual behavior does what I worry
about and why I'm running is that
politics itself has become a
conversation unworthy of the energies
that need to emerge at this time these
are very serious times and we need to be
very serious people we need to have an
integrative approach we need to think
about these things in terms of how
people feel not just in terms of how
they think what the deeper needs of
human beings are in order to thrive just
like in 1776 our founders they posited a
different possibility for Humanity and
that's what I and I believe millions of
us would like to see
in the 21st century you know if in fact
the purpose of our lives is to love one
another there is no reason not to apply
that to public policy because I'll tell
you if you look at what we have now and
the state of our world now how we doing
how we doing I think we might have a
little disagreement here too because
we're doing pretty well there really
yeah and I are doing well no no I mean
the world there's infant mortality rates
are at the lowest they've ever been
there's less violence there's ever been
there's less but there's less people
starving now than there were 50 well I
agree with that but yeah I mean hold on
hold on are you that 12,000 a day well
I'm not saying the world's perfect but
almost all of the the metrics that we
can judge a successful road on that
everything is trending better well you
and I would certainly have a longer
conversation about that first of all I'm
an optimist and I yeah I'm someone like
you who has benefitted from the high
side of the marketplace when it works
and the American capitalism one where I
get the high side and I get that if
you're in the club this is the best
place in the world to be we're living at
a time Dave we're not enough people can
get into the club when you have one
percent of Americans owning more wealth
than the bottom 90% what you've got is
what I said before the 40 percent of
Americans who can't even have a shot we
talked about the economy as good who is
the economy good for and we look at the
low end unemployment rates but you
realize how many people have to work two
three jobs a day just in order to pay
the rent just in order to pay the rent
for a modest two-bedroom apartment
there's a huge sea of unnecessary human
suffering so I don't think I fail to see
the the good stuff but I believe it's
our responsibility particularly as
people particularly as people who have
won in ways that we have won to concern
ourselves with the benefit of all you
can do better look at the state of our
planet look at the state of our
environmental crisis look at the fact
that we have so many we have seven
thousand seven thousand nuclear bombs in
our own
personal look at the fact that we're
talking about who has nuclear bombs and
we know that there are people working
every single day to to get their hands
on one who are the worst people could
possibly get their hands on one and
would seek to do his harm and and and
the fact that even recently we almost
had a military strike against Iran that
was stopped only ten ten minutes before
it was planned we've got some very very
serious problems that's why I want a
department of peace I want us to wage
peace as assiduously and as effectively
as we prepare for war I know you
wouldn't want to give it to him but does
Trump deserve some credit for not doing
that strike if you get it you got a call
a minute before and now in terms of Iran
know it was the president who got who
recklessly removed us from the Iran
nuclear deal that is what led up to that
the president taking us out of the Iran
nuclear deal out of a situation that was
an international leveraging where by all
indicators Iran was that we know of the
Iran was compliant so now they've said
the other day that they're going to go
on in enriched uranium beyond what the
agreement called for because we had
pulled out no I cannot give the
president any credit for what's
happening with Iran the fact that he was
about to do something so unbelievably
reckless because let me tell you
something given the size of the Iranian
army alone you think Iraq was a
catastrophe nothing compared to what war
with Iran would look like so obviously
some hero we don't know exactly who it
was but we know someone within the
higher echelons of either his
administration its national security
apparatus or the military talked him out
of it that we can be very thankful to
this person whoever they were the one
place will give some credit to it to the
president somebody had to stand up to
China I'll give him that
alright so let's let's I want to be
respectful of your time here so let's
just knock out a couple other issues so
the one thing that you brought up that
nobody brings up in a presidential
debate you brought up food and yeah eat
yes and this actually seemed to strike a
chord with people yeah we don't have a
health care system in this country we
have a sickness care system what we do
is we have a higher level of chronic
illness than any of the other advanced
countries
and then what we talk about is who's
going to pay for our health care what we
really need to talk about is why are we
so sick and if you're going to do that
then you have to look at our our
environmental policies we have an
administration that is done at the clean
air act go to the clean water act
overturn the ban on pesticides that are
absolutely scientifically proven to harm
and developing child's brain why because
our EPA instead of actually acting as an
Environmental Protection Agency now is
headed by a former chemical company
executive and before that by former oil
company executive we have to talk about
our food policies and they the deef the
D juicing of the FDA we have to talk
about our agricultural policies we have
to talk about our chemical policies even
our economic policies given that so much
stress underlies so much chronic illness
so absolutely and this this is the thing
many Democrats what I want to see the
Democrats do is more than just address
the suffering which they do more than
not and I respect that and I'm very
grateful to be a Democrat for that
reason but we need to do more than that
we need to challenge the underlying
forces that make all that suffering
inevitable so we have to do more than
provide health care as important as that
is and I want universal health care and
I stand for the public option in
addition to the Obamacare etcetera yeah
how would you allow for private health
care that's easy so you would okay
because that does seem to be an agent of
change I don't want to be an agent of
chaos if we come in too hard on one
issue like that we're gonna lock the
brakes yeah you know we have to be
thinking in terms of governing here yeah
well that's interesting because that's
one of the ones where to me it's like
all right you want Medicare for all okay
I can I'm not a big government guy but
yeah I can kind of get there so that
everyone can have it but if you're gonna
then tell people they can't have private
insurance I'm with you on that yeah let
me ask you a question you say not a big
government guy but don't you see it as a
function of government regulations
safety and health regulation so there
isn't the spewing of carcinogens in our
air spearing of carcinogens and toxins
in our water yeah well I didn't say I'm
a no government but I will try to roll
back as many regulations as possible as
a general rule safety regulations Dave
well no I didn't say every regulation I
want to make sure that's what so many
people on the other side certainly the
corporate aside yeah the Court decide
dared get government out get government
out
business killing first of all you you
have to create more jobs by having to to
answer to some of these regulations
there are proper regulations because it
takes people to do that yeah so we have
so many carcinogens so many toxins and
our food in our water in our air in
these horrifying pesticides so
absolutely if we're gonna have a real
health care conversation in America and
that's what I want to do as president I
don't want to just talk about how we're
gonna how we're going to help you when
you're sick I want to talk about how the
government and how that just the
government how this society can work in
such a way there's so many of us aren't
sick to begin with okay a couple more
quick we'll try to do them quick it
seems like everyone's kind of veering to
some version of open borders that that's
some I have not heard one candidate well
they won't say it but oh but the
policies team no you don't say it but
you really mean ways is that is that
healthy honorable debate you say it if
you believe it I don't believe it you
can have no I take them at their word
and it seems to me that the policies
ultimately are why why if you say we
should have proper security at the
border but that is going to take
remember the president has closed a lot
of the ports of entry that is what has
created so much of the squeeze here
because he's closed so many of the of
the border entry points of course we
need we need border enforcement of
course we need more judges of course we
need more agents of course we need more
technology that to me goes without
saying he is withdrawn those things and
that is created more of a drama but I do
believe that borders should organize our
our societies they shouldn't divide our
hearts and the idea of compassionate
immigration laws has been one of the
golden threads in the in the tapestry of
American history my own grandparents
came here to Ellis Island escaping
pogroms in Russia so so when you when
you stop seeing you know asylum even
what he's doing right now asylum in the
United States seeking asylum is
a crime it's a statutory right this is
the basic to the American heart if we
stop being but what about the people
that aren't coming through the proper
channels I'm with you seeking asylum of
course is not and especially people that
are seeking it from truly tyrannical
people to come to proper channels by
closing more of the so called proper
channels the president hasn't done this
Ronald Reagan gave amnesty to 8 million
people before 1973 if you were if you
were an undocumented person you know
what you did you walked over to the
registry office this is a made-up thing
this is what dictators do this is what
authoritarian figures do it's found a
group of powerless people and you can
scapegoat them and make them the enemy
when in fact the immigrant in the United
States does as much for us as we do for
the immigrant now where did your
ancestors come here from from Russia and
from Belarus but I'm not I'm not again
not anti immigrant I'm with you on that
I'm saying you have to figure out a way
to come here legally right and that
seems to be the lot of it I think most
Americans want yeah I mean I think a lot
of times they're just conflating the
difference between coming illegally and
legal immigrants so that we realize this
at this point it is made so difficult
for so many people you know you look at
something like daca I mean are they
legal whether or not legal but what
fault of it is there it's not their
fault that they're not and at a certain
point what are you gonna do it's like I
was looking at her last night I think it
was on Rachel Maddow she was showing one
of the debate between Hillary Clinton
and Donald Trump and she was she was
saying it she was she was so prescient
she was warning us like Rachel Maddow
said don't don't tell us you weren't
warned all right two more okay $15
minimum wage are you for it or against
it well I'm for it and I realized there
are some communities for whom it's too
big a leap so I believe that the
government should provide subsidies and
compensatory measures in the meantime
because you did some there are some
neighborhoods and some communities in
this country but which it would just be
it would be too too difficult but that
definitely needs to be the goal and in
those cases I want the government to
compensate so that we can get there so
if I wanted to hire somebody here just
the PA or somebody to fill water glasses
and thing
you would want the government to be able
to tell me no Michael no because we're
in Los Angeles and you can afford $15 an
hour theoretically well right but it's
not about what I can theoretically
afford or not if I is how is that so if
I but because I have tons of people that
would love to work for me for free we
pay our interns I don't have I don't
want anyone I pay a hundred percent of
all my employees health insurance I
don't want anyone to work for me for
free but the idea that the government
could come in if I wanted to pay someone
say $12 because I could have several
people do it for free the idea that the
government could come in and tell me
something like fast-food restaurants
okay yeah so 20 years ago somebody
worked as a at a fast-food restaurant as
a after school you know they were young
people today this is how people pay
their bills and have to have two and
three jobs there are but if you force
those companies to pay those people or
aren't they just gonna replace those
people with iPads I mean we see that
happening now well that's why we're
gonna need it you're not gonna like this
that's why we're gonna need a universal
basic income because we have a tsunami
of automation that's coming at us but we
might now have a situation where there
the way the wages are in certain
industries a person would have to work a
hundred and forty-four hours a week in
order to be able to afford a modest
two-bedroom apartment you can't have
people living at this level of horror
they a man said to me I've been think
about this for the last few weeks he was
talking about how and he's a
conservative Republican lovely lovely
man and he was talking about how he said
I presided over the I think it was the
meatpacking industry in Iowa he said
when men used to make fifteen
$18 an hour wait some of the $20 an hour
they make good livings they raise their
families he said I was here when
immigrants came into this neighborhood
who would do it for six hours $6 an hour
and I had to break the news to these
guys I'm sorry fellas I you know they'll
do it for six so what the it wasn't
until after I left him that I thought
well hello that's why you're supposed to
have unions that's why it should have
been that's why
an attack on unions is such an attack on
the ability of working people to thrive
the problem there was not the fact that
the immigrants came the problem there
was the fact that there were that there
were unions and that there wasn't a
minimum wage all right one more okay
healing crystals what's the story what's
the deal I was going to burn some
incense before you got here we were
gonna do a seance I have a Ouija board
over there I know the word orb
everything is orbs I don't think I ever
even kind of knew you don't have an aura
before I think it's something in a
photograph
I love geodes so you don't have any
healing crystals not here not that I
don't think they're a wonderful thing by
the way I think I think stones have
power and all that but no that's I'm not
that kind of you know it's just I don't
have any judgment on it but number one
is I'm just not that kind of person
number two I do think the mean some of
them are earlier we all ought to think
very deeply there's a reason why a
certain group of people want me to be
seen as wacky there is a political media
industrial complex in this country and
there's this assumption that that inside
of game should rule this country in a
way that's not the US Constitution this
country belongs to We the People and
that I'm one of those people and so are
you and the founders looked to us and to
all of your viewers to be making the
decisions that will determine where this
country goes no gatekeepers not in
America
that's pretty good closing statement I
had big I've thoroughly enjoyed this and
I and for whatever those little
disagreements are mean that's exactly
why I do this show and I wish we had
more time to flesh numbers out and
hopefully you'll keep going and maybe
you can do this again thank you I hope
so what about one one healing crystal
for everyone would you run that I could
go for a tax increase on that not going
not gonna happen okay
for more on marry an elective assume we
brought it around for Barad Marion check
out her campaign website at Mary Ann
comm know
no no no Marion 2020 calm is that your
personal income is my personal so that's
the old you know no very good butter my
campaign
Marianne 2020 what you did become a
politician that was slick ver more I'm
area check out her campaign website at
Marion 2020 dot-com and if you're new
here click the subscribe button then
make sure that you click the bell so
it's solid and you get notified when the
videos come out
thank you very much thank you very much